the word progressive is being thrown
around a lot this election season I have
a progressive who gets things done you
can't go and say you're a moderate on
one day and be a progressive on the
other day we've been fighting the
progressive fight and getting results
for people for years but what's a
progressive anyway progressives
generally believed that government
policies should be used to increase
social and economic equality and the
well-being and safety of citizens both
at home and abroad but many folks have
different ideas about what achieving
these goals looks like now everyone
knows Bernie Sanders as a progressive
candidate but what about Hillary Clinton
well her relationship with wall street
and the millions she's earned from paid
speaking gigs as an ouster are you
willing to release the transcripts of
all your paid speeches I will look into
it I don't know the status but I will
certainly look into it her hawkish
foreign policy which includes having
voted for the Iraq war her history with
the dreaded establishment and the
support she's received from super PACs
have all set her to the right of Bernie
I am very proud to be the only candidate
akhiya who does not have a super PAC
who's not raising
but some of Clinton's positions might
surprise you for instance Clinton
opposes the trans-pacific partnership
agreement after going back and forth on
it she supports the Iran deal although
she has threatened military action if
Iran violates any part of it Clinton
also wants to expand the Affordable Care
Act to universal health care and sure
Sanders has always been consistent on
those issues but there are two areas
where hillary out progresses even him
immigration and gun control i don't
think it was progressive to vote against
Ted Kennedy's immigration reform in 2007
then senator Clinton was in favor of
advancing a comprehensive immigration
reform bill that would have put millions
of undocumented immigrants on the path
towards citizenship that was a bill that
Bernie Sanders voted to block and here's
the thing she wants comprehensive
immigration reform she wants to end
family deportation and shut down private
detention centers she even wants to
expand health care access to
undocumented immigrants and she's vowed
not only to protect President Obama's
executive actions on immigration that
would defer the deportations of a
potential five million people but also
to take it even further then there's gun
control an issue Clinton has used to set
herself apart from Sanders I don't think
it was
immunity Clinton's repeatedly
co-sponsored legislation that would
require background checks at gun shows
Sanders voted against the Brady Bill
legislation that requires background
checks for gun purchases so maybe it's
true there are some days she can be well
kind of progressive on some things and
for what it's worth in her last two
years of senator both Clinton and
Sanders voted the same on issues
ninety-three percent of the time so
given all of that do you think Hillary
Clinton is a progressive